et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Raquel garretto bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous la France insoumise de
la Seine-Saint-Denis on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
qu'on présentait par Julien l'Écuyer de
la Voix du Nord bonjour
on va
dans le pays ces derniers jours à quelle
gare d'eau avec vous avec vous et hier
le Sénat à auditionné Gérald Darmanin le
ministre de l'Intérieur sur les émeutes
de ces derniers jours il en a fait le
bilan il a défendu sa gestion de ses
émeutes est-ce que l'exécutif a bien
géré la situation
non non mais après il y a situation et
situation je fais une différence entre
le meurtre de Naël et j'utilise meurtre
non pas parce que je m'attribue le droit
de qualifier juridiquement les faits
mais parce que c'est la qualification
juridique qui est retenue à ce stade
pour le moment par les autres par
l'autorité judiciaire que ce soit le
procureur la justice donc c'est pour ça
homicide volontaire c'est meurtre et ça
n'est pas rien ça n'est pas rien que
justement la qualification retenue soit
le meurtre et que le policier en cause
soit en détention provisoire ça n'est
pas rien c'est c'est plutôt nouveau dans
le traitement de ces affaires là ça
c'est la première situation et ça généré
une réplique une réplique dans la
société mais je sais ce que c'est pas la
peine situation
des policiers ça prouve en tout cas que
côté judiciaire
et il y a eu après après il faut quand
même se dire après la circulation de la
vidéo
c'est quand même on n'est pas naïf on le
sait tous que il y a avant et après la
vidéo et que c'est la vidéo qui change
tout du coup ça veut dire qu'on peut pas
en rester au traitement judiciaire on
peut pas juste dire bon ben c'est un cas
individuel traité par la justice
et puis politiquement il y a rien à
faire non là c'est celle-là qui c'est là
où le gouvernement n'a pas bien géré si
vous voulez mon avis parce qu'il y avait
des choses à dire sur
ce que révèle cette homicide volontaire
et il révèle un problème systémique dans
la police qui est de deux ordres le
premier et c'est Henri Leclerc qui
l'avait dit sur votre plateau très
rapidement après l'effet il avait 100%
raison la question de l'article
435-1 au minimum le quatrièmement de du
code de la sécurité intérieure qui est
le fameux article qui permet un policier
d'utiliser son arme dans la ou dans le
cas où il pense que la personne est
susceptible de voyez c'est des un
vocabulaire tellement flou que ça a
généré une explosion du nombre de du
jazz de l'arme et de nombre de morts
donc là il y a un problème et puis il y
a l'autre problème aussi Qui est qui est
la question du racisme c'est-à-dire on
ne peut pas se permettre de laisser
prospérer dans la police
des opinions racistes qui sont
elles-mêmes des délits on va déjà
revenir sur la première question parce
que hier Gérald Darmanin on a parlé lors
de son audition de ce fameux article que
vous comptez c'est dit c'est pas parce
qu'un policier ne respecte pas la loi
qu'il faut changer la loi est-ce qu'il
n'a pas raison
non il n'a pas raison parce que en
l'occurrence c'est d'abord qu'il n'a pas
respecté la loi c'est le tribunal qui le
dira à la fin la cour d'appel j'imagine
la Cour de cassation etc
attendons d'accord sur ce cas spécifique
la qualification juridique ultime des
faits sera donné par la fin de la
procédure et j'ai quand même noté dans
dans l'énoncé des faits par le procureur
que les mis en cause parlaient de du
fait que y pensait qu'il y avait un
risque de mise en cause de la de
l'intégrité physique des patients etc
donc ils ont tout à fait intégré ce
vocabulaire de l'article à 135-1 et les
circuler un non respect de la loi est-ce
que c'est pour ça qu'il faut changer la
loi parce qu'un policier n'entre pas ce
que je vais vous dire c'est que c'est
pas certain que la justice aboutira ou
non respect de la loi ils vont plaider
que c'était la loi ils vont le [__] et
et et c'est inacceptable de la part du
ministre de l'intérieur de ne pas
regarder en face ce problème de
l'article
sont les faits vis-à-vis de la mort
tragique de Naël c'est qu'il faut aussi
regarder l'ensemble des des faits suite
à la au vote de la loi de 2017
le traitement judiciaire de l'homicide
volontaire de Naël il faut absolument
changer la doctrine d'emploi de la force
armée dans la police il y a la question
de la circulaire il y a la question de
la loi elle-même on a fait un petit peu
d'archéologie on était retourné en 2017
voir les débats à l'époque le Sénat
avait changé le texte etc il y avait des
députés pour yamir Shahi qui avait dit
que on crée une zone de zone grise qui
allait qu'elle est belligène qui allait
être criminogène et et c'était tout à
fait vrai
qu'ils sont en augmentation et ben
comment on fait madame
on tire sur les gens puisque non mais
puisque
vous voulez faire pour répondre à cette
situation
35-1 n'est pas un article sur le refus
d'obtempérer le refus d'obtempérer c'est
un délit à part qui est puni un criminé
etc sanctionné l'article 435-1 est un
article sur l'usage de l'arme d'accord
de l'ordre dans le cadre notamment donc
en fait c'est ça qu'il faut qu'il faut
mettre à plat c'est à quel moment c'est
absolument nécessaire
utile efficace dans la lutte contre la
délinquance et la criminalité d'utiliser
l'arme c'est tout je veux dire les
conducteurs de ce pays les ceux qui
lisent Automoto et tout ça je pense que
ils sont d'accord avec moi pour dire que
les délais routiers ne doivent pas
entraîner la mort des des conducteurs
est-ce que vous avez entendu c'est le
président de la commission des des lois
sachahouliers qui a parlé d'une mission
d'évaluation de ce de cette loi à la
rentrée est-ce que vous y souscrivez et
ce que vous vous satisfaisez qu'il y a
un bouger de la part de la majorité
là-dessus oui et bien sûr et je pense
qu'ils ont mis ils ont un peu tardé et
puis c'est pas voilà seulement au niveau
de Sacha Olivier qu'il faut le dire que
le président de la commission des lois
le disent c'est très bien et il faut
évidemment s'ils engagent effectivement
une telle une telle mission nous en
serons moi je suis manque de la
partition des lois justement de la
commission des lois donc c'est un
travail législatif important
urgent sur lequel il y a du recul mais
vas-y participer vous souhaitez que ce
soit de toute façon nous nous sommes
membres de la commission des lois nous
faisons notre travail mais là ce que je
veux dire c'est que c'est pas la peine
de patienter c'est pas la peine
d'attendre j'ai entendu beaucoup de
discours qui disent on peut pas
réfléchir à chaud mais c'est pas à chaud
c'est il y a déjà eu 13 morts l'année
dernière donc on n'est pas à chaud il y
a du recul depuis 2017 il y a des
comparaisons aussi à faire avec la
gendarmerie etc il y a des on a un recul
donc ça ça fait partie des choses que le
gouvernement aurait pu d'ores et déjà
annoncé comme un chantier rapide de
toute façon il y en a deux c'est Arctic
435-1 quatrièmement pour être vraiment
allé au plus au plus au plus polémique
on va dire au plus au plus problématique
et la question du racisme et la juste
pardon pour finir mais comme il y a une
mission qui va être lancée est-ce que
vous maintenez votre proposition de loi
d'abrogation de cet article ou est-ce
que du coup vous là re décalez à plus
tard en attendant les conclusions de
cette mission de toute façon il y a
plusieurs propositions de loi sur la
table et Sophie tailler polliant les
insoumis Sabrina sebahi qui est député
de Nanterre et travail aussi donc tout
ça va converger de vous avez vu comment
fonctionne l'Assemblée nationale
aujourd'hui de toute façon l'Élysée n'y
est pas majoritaire donc quand il y a
des majorités c'est que c'est que un
moment donné on a additionné plusieurs
continuer sur cette proposition de loi
quand même malgré cette mission
d'information oui bien sûr mais mais moi
je suis moi je suis très pragmatique je
veux qu'on change cette loi bien vite et
j'en fais pas une question dogmatique
j'en fais pas une question pour me
singulariser je veux sauver des vies qui
est normalement aussi l'objectif de la
police
a annoncé qu'un projet de loi de
d'urgence pour la reconstruction des
bâtiments municipaux serait examinés
alors dans l'idéal avant la poser
estivale est-ce que là aussi c'est
quelque chose que vous pouvez soutenir
alors non là pour le coup
Muriel
premièrement parce que parce que il
s'agit de changer les règles de
l'urbanisme pour contourner les les
appels voilà les marchés publics et pour
réduire les élèves pour pouvoir
construire tout ça d'accord mais sur le
modèle de ce qui a été fait par exemple
pour Notre-Dame oui bon mais ce qu'il
faut ce qui compte vraiment pour les
municipalités pour les pour là où il y a
eu des dommages d'abord c'est la
question quand même de l'engagement
financier parce que il parallèlement à
ça le ministre de l'Économie dit on
lâchera plus un seul euro pour les
banlieues etc bon donc faudrait savoir
et puis surtout surtout il faut une loi
d'urgence pour l'immatériel c'est
l'immatériel qui est le gros souci le
matériel ça se reconstruit c'est
l'immatériel qu'il faut soigner dans ce
pays et c'est sur ce point moi ce qui me
frappe c'est à quel point les autorités
n'ont rien à dire sur justement la
fabrication de de la paix dans notre
pays il y a une forte aspiration à la
paix nous devons obtenir la paix la paix
et le consentement la paix c'est la
démocratie c'est le fait que nous soyons
d'accord avec les règles parce que on
voit bien que la loi est la volonté
générale et c'est ça qui est en panne
aujourd'hui pourquoi parce que vous avez
un gouvernement qui est oligarchique
dans le sens où il concentre le pouvoir
on l'a vu avec le président et ses 49-3
successifs on l'a vu le conflit des
retraites a eu une dimension
démocratique très pédagogique tous les
Français ont compris que nous avions
désormais 49-3 raisons de passer à la
Sixième République et puis 49-3 vous
aviez le pouvoir déposer d'émotions
censure ce que vous avez fait qui ont
échoué oui mais c'est pas la même vous
êtes d'accord avec moi que votre santé
que de voter la loi vous étiez là le 16
mars à nous observer les 577 députés
lorsque nous étions tout prêt à voter et
que juste parce qu'ils étaient pas
certains du résultat l'Élysée a enlevé à
enlever ce vote c'est que c'est pour le
pays pour le monde entier ça a été un
choc un électrochoc démocratique et face
à ce risque là parce que l'absence de
modalité Pacifique pour faire la loi et
belligène génère de l'attention dans la
société et mince vient se rajouter une
autre tension une autre source de guerre
qui est cette petite culture cette
musique de la guerre civile
qu'entretient l'extrême droite et la
droite sénatoriale la droite c'est la
terre je dois dire l'extrême droite et
la droite de jour là ce que disent
monsieur Retailleau et la sénatrice du
Val-d'Oise dont j'oublie voilà c'est une
c'est une culture de la guerre civile
c'est-à-dire si l'idée que on va
distinguer entre français
de leur point de vue à eux et ils
oublient la base de ce qu'est l'histoire
de notre pays et la citoyenneté la
France est une nation civique pas une
nation ethnique et c'est l'immigré qui
vous le dit moi je suis arrivée en
France à l'âge de 14 ans je suis devenu
françaises à l'âge de 25 ans voilà je
j'ai repris mes études à 30 ans quand
mes enfants les petites elles avaient
grandi elles sont sorties des couches je
sors surtout retourner à l'université je
suis devenue avocate à 48 ans je deviens
député je n'accepte pas que des
sénateurs disent qui est les bons
Français qui n'est pas bon français nous
sommes nous sommes égaux et dire le
contraire c'est semer la graine de la
guerre civile ce qui est profondément
dangereux profondément inacceptable
systémique de la société française dont
vous parliez
c'est une expression raciste ça c'est
évident comme quand monsieur Retailleau
parle d'origine ethnique il y a une
obsession pour les origines une
obsession pour les sortes de régression
vers les origines ethniques de la part
de la deuxième et troisième génération
c'est délirant c'est absolument c'est
fou comme expression c'est fou comme
expression parce que ça met une question
hiérarchie etc en fait bon Bruno
Retailleau fait partie d'une tradition
politique française qui est pas récente
qui date de 230 ans eux n'ont jamais
accepté qu'à la Révolution française en
face de la France une nation civique
c'est-à-dire où précisément l'ethnie la
religion etc était indifférente c'est ça
c'est en cela que la République est
grande et qu'elle est magnifique et que
et que c'est pour ça qu'on y adhère et
que c'est et je le vois avec mon propre
parcours d'immigré c'est si facile
d'être français en réalité parce que on
a une conception de la patrie qui est
une patrie républicaine avec ses droits
universels mais il y a toujours eu
toujours eu depuis le début depuis le
début et notamment en Vendée des gens
qui n'étaient pas d'accord avec la
France républicaine et bien cela il faut
les mettre en minorité et il faut que
nous la majorité des Français qui sommes
pour la République pour la paix et pour
justement qu'il n'y ait pas de
discrimination qui n'est pas de racisme
c'est nous qui devons vaincre mais ce
combat est devant nous il y a les
tenants de la nation ethnique les
tenants de la nation civique pour le
moment dans l'histoire de France nous
avons gagné mais ce combat est encore
devant de nous parce que les forces qui
qui sont obsédés par l'ethnie des autres
sont quand même actuellement en train de
se réarmer et c'est un problème j'ai
entendu ok rideaux dans vos mots
le semis de paix d'apaisement vous vous
martelez là-dessus et en même temps et
les filles étaient mises en cause pour
ses propos Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui qui
n'appelait pas au calme je rappelle
aussi Alma Dufour qui twitait qu'il ne
se passe jamais rien sans rapport de
force et que oui la fin justifie les
moyens est-ce que c'est propre à
alimenter la paix donc vous souhaitez
que vous souhaitez alors
je pense que
politique
calme ça veut rien dire on calme une
pierre et inerte elle est calme quand je
suis dans mon jardin je prends le soleil
je suis calme le calme ça ne veut ça ne
s'est pas parlant en politique pour moi
ce qui est parlant c'est la paix qui est
une construction alors est-ce que vous
en venir les morts
je ne joue pas sur les mots parce que
calme et pas calme c'est justement le
vocabulaire bah de l'oligarchie et de
l'extrême droite et donc effectivement
il ne fallait pas entrer dans cette
latéralité là effectivement ne pas
appeler au calme c'est en fait il
fallait non mais rien selon moi récuser
je pense que elle m'a Dufour fait
référence au combat progressiste par
exemple elle-même est une est une
activiste en matière environnementale
justification de la violence ben je le
sais que de sa part ça n'est pas mais en
tout cas nous n'avons pas le droit je
pense à ce niveau de la compétition et
compte tenu du risque que toutes nos une
erreur ou nous ou nos défauts de
calibrage dans l'expression soit
utilisée par l'extrême droite et
l'oligarchie je pense qu'il faut faire
attention je préfère que nous incarnions
la paix la paix qui est une construction
comme je l'ai dit et qui passe aussi et
là c'est le combat que je mène à
l'Assemblée nationale avec le groupe de
travail que je pilote le groupe de
travail nups pour la 6e République il va
falloir qu'on se regarde tous les
Français et qu'on se dise malgré nos
désaccords est-ce qu'on est capable
encore de faire une patrie commune
est-ce qu'on est capable de se doter
d'institutions d'une sixième république
on peut qui nous permettront qui nous
permettra d'être en désaccord mais
est-ce que certains chez vous a commencé
par Jean-Luc Mélenchon n'ont pas fait
une erreur dans la période actuelle
écoutez moi ça fait 30 ans que je me
dise avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon j'ai fait
les trois campagnes présidentielles
personne montera voilà tout ce que j'ai
fait la loyauté etc mais je vous le dis
je veux pas être porte-parole à vie de
des expressions de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
donc vous avez une difficulté avec ce
qu'il a dit demandez à Monsieur
mise en difficulté
et moi je vous dis comment je pense
qu'il faut s'exprimer parce que je le
fais je veux pas commencer
avec ces expressions je fais encore
je ne suis pas en difficulté car je me
sens pleinement responsable moi de ma
part de pouvoir j'ai une certaine
éthique de de du pouvoir je suis député
désormais je compte pleinement utiliser
ce pouvoir pour faire avancer mon pays
notamment en facilitant le fait qu'on
passe à la Sixième République qui est
une tâche importante en profondeur que
nous menons avec sérieux c'est ça que je
souhaite incarner on entend ce que vous
dites vous avez votre voix propre mais
vous êtes aussi une représentante de la
France insoumise France insoumise qui
est aussi représenté par une voie encore
plus forte
celle de Jean-Luc Mélenchon est-ce qu'à
un moment donné cette divergence de vues
sur l'expression sur même la stratégie
sur la façon même de concevoir la
communication politique ne va pas créer
un schisme au sein de LFI non pas de
schisme mais simplement admettez que du
coup ben peut-être on peut tous
concevoir que personne n'est infaillible
voilà ce que ça montre surtout c'est il
faut tous sortir du côté Sauveur là moi
ce qui me frappe quand j'observe la vie
politique française c'est qu'il y a
toujours cette idée que il faut pas
Sauveur c'est à dire on est dans une
monarchie présidentielle notre
institution la Cinquième République est
une monarchie présidentielle et la vie
politique s'articule autour de gens qui
va être monarque à la place du monarque
et bien moi je dis c'est avec ça qu'il
faut rompre ce que j'aime à la nupes ce
que j'adore à la nupaisse c'est qu'un
UPS c'est chorale c'est collégial c'est
ça qui compte et c'est pour moi c'est ça
la force donc vous trouverez vous ne
trouverez jamais personne qui ne fait
pas d'erreur de de qui ne fait pas
d'erreur ça n'existe pas donc arrêtons
avec ce rêve là et construisons quelque
chose de plus adulte la nups justement
sur ce thème des des émeutes semble plus
en effet dissonante que convergente j'en
veux pour preuve Olivier Faure qui avait
évoqué j'allais dire presque comme vous
en profonde désaccord avec Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et ajouter qu'on ne peut pas
donner le sentiment d'encouragé
d'accepter la violence la seule réponse
qu'il a eu c'est pas celle de dire oui
peut-être qu'il y a eu une expression
maladroite c'est de Manuel Bompard qui
lui a rappelé qui a pointé du doigt le
fait qu'il avait voté la loi Cazenove et
est-ce que c'est comme ça vraiment qu'on
qu'on sait l'Union et qu'on alimente la
la cohésion je pense qu'il faut il vaut
mieux se concentrer sur le conflit qui
est réel et qui est sans doute beaucoup
plus au mérite que nous avons avec
l'extrême droite et avec l'oligarchie
genre aujourd'hui oui quand même un
petit peu là c'est à dire que je pense
qu'on ne peut pas se permettre c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs que toutes ces
histoires autour des européennes des
sénatoriales et tout ça on va en dire un
mot mais juste pour
sur la ligne qui qui n'a pas lieu d'être
vous avez entendu cette semaine une fois
de plus en dire que la France insoumise
ne se situe plus dans le champ
républicain est-ce que du coup vous
n'êtes pas abîmé par cette voix chez
vous qui font tirer ses conclusions mais
cette expression est gravissime et
gravissante d'abord parce que elle nie
elle nie
l'action politique qui doit naître du
meurtre de Naël c'est-à-dire quand comme
le gouvernement ne se focalise que sur
la question des dégradations qui ont eu
lieu des des émeutes etc il ne parle que
de ça mais
si dans le monde face au maire les
chantiers évoqués par le Président de la
République il s'attache aussi au reste
du problème puisque d'abord pas la
question de la réforme à la police je
suis désolé la réforme de la police
j'en ai parlé au maire de ma
circonscription
et c'est consternant à quel point les
réponses de gouvernement sont vraiment
comme je disais la loi d'urgence sur le
matériel et rien sur l'immatériel rien
sur l'humain rien et c'est ça le
problème donc et vous avez les questions
au Gouvernement hier et on a vraiment
l'impression que le responsable de tous
et la France insoumise tout ça
c'est-à-dire le meurtre de Naël les
dégradations etc tout est la faute et la
France en soumise là je trouve que c'est
c'est grave parce que ça veut dire que
on y on nie le rôle qu'a un gouvernement
ou quand il doit gouverner le
gouvernement il doit prendre des
décisions sur la question de la police
et je le répète à la troisième fois que
j'essaie de vous en parler le racisme
dans la police c'est un problème ils
doivent le traiter mais ça évidemment
que c'est un problème systémique il y a
pas dépolliciers qui pourraient faire
des actes de racisme pour vous il y a un
racisme systémique dans la police madame
à la fin un policier plus un policier
plus un policier ça fait quand même
beaucoup de policiers donc de toute
façon une hiérarchie il y a une chaîne
de commandement et ça n'est pas possible
d'accepter cette forme de délinquance
parce que encore une fois le racisme est
une délinquance on ne peut pas accepter
la délinquance au sein de la police
est-ce qu'il y a une un problème
d'autorité parentale je me posais la
question parce que vous voyez venir le
président de la République a noté que il
fallait réfléchir à une meilleure
responsabilisation des parents peut-être
via aussi des amendes plus systématiques
dès le premier fait qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez je pense que cette attaque
contre les familles et la marque de la
culture de l'impunité qui est la marque
de la Cinquième République la Cinquième
République qu'est-ce qu'il a caractérise
c'est que la personne qui a le plus de
pouvoir gouvernants qui concentre le
plus de pouvoir gouvernants le président
de la République et irresponsable au
sens constitutionnel du terme ne rendent
compte à personne ça n'existe dans
aucune autre démocratie cette façon de
faire de la politique donc ça crée une
culture de l'impunité politique une
culture de ces jeux hein je fais ce que
je veux parce que j'ai été élu vous
m'avez mis là je suis président donc les
retraites à 64 ans et ainsi de suite je
fais ce que je veux et deuxièmement
sur une élection qui concerne 160 000
électeurs et sur lesquels là il y aurait
dans 14 départements sur quoi sur 50 un
accord entre trois parties parce que
parce que par ailleurs personne n'a
réussi à se mettre d'accord sur les
autres départements la vérité sur les
sénatoriales c'est que c'est une
élections
entre entre sénateurs localement ça
donne lieu à des choses qui sont
innommables parfois vous verrez par
exemple
personne ne l'a souligné ça à droite
parfois ils sont d'accord entre eux mais
ils présentent plusieurs listes pourquoi
pour contourner les règles sur la parité
parce qu'il préfère élire trois têtes de
liste homme plutôt que de faire des
listes
pour vous c'est pas que cet accord se
fasse en vous caresser les oreilles
évidemment je pense que ça aurait été
intelligent de de proposer une place de
sénateur aux insoumis qui peu cher ne
demandait pas grand chose mais une fois
bon ils ont ils ont pas le temps
sur les sénatoriales a priori pas
d'accord non plus sur les européennes la
nups était avant tout un accord
électoral est-ce que ça veut pas dire
que finalement on s'achemine vers la fin
de la nups moi je ne le laisserai pas
faire donc je serai parti des personnes
qui
feront tout pour que la nupais soit en
mesure de gouverner encore une fois je
pense que il faut qu'on sorte de la
culture de monarque à la place du
monarque et je vois la nupesse comme
cette outil de la prise de pouvoir
démocratique avec une nouvelle culture
je suis par exemple je pense que quand
on va aux élections présidentielles il
faut dire qui va être le ou la première
ministre il faut le dire parce que c'est
l'article 20 de la Constitution le
Premier ministre détermine et conduit la
politique de la nation il faut dire le
gouvernement faut dire adosser ça à
l'élection législative comment on
l'avait fait d'ailleurs là ce qui était
intéressant en juin 2022 c'est elysée
moi Premier ministre on oublie pas le
premier ministre mais c'était très
subversif et très intéressant merci
beaucoup merci Raquel d'avoir été notre
invité ce matin c'est les vacances à la
Une de La Voix du Nord
attention à la côte merci Julien à la
semaine prochaine on passe au club des
territoires